in the last few minutes the Home  Secretary has warned Christmas travelers  to think carefully about their plans  after border force staff announced  strike action over the festive period  they join a long list of public sector  employees walking out overpay and  conditions and this morning swella  bravaman said she will not compromise on  security at the border  I really want to urge people who have  got plans to travel abroad to think  carefully about their plans because they  may well be impacted ultimately you know  I'm not willing to compromise on  security at the border that's the number  one priority so uh you know that may  well have another an adverse impact on  you know convenience for people frankly  whether it's the time that they may have  to wait for flights or you know  departures they may well be delayed in  on arrivals and various travel plans  um ultimately security at the border is  my number one non-negotiable priority